gibt es sie eigentlich noch wirklich
große prägende revolutionäre philosophen
ja es gibt sie und einer der wenigen
denker auf denen eine solche
beschreibung ohne jede einschränkung
zutrifft sitzt mir im augenblick
gegenübersitzt amerikaner john searle
dessen thesen und gedankenexperimente
die welt philosophie seit mehr als 50
jahren den atem und bewegung halten
er soll das ist eine große freude und
ehre sei dir zu haben herzlich
die freude ist ganz meinerseits das jahr
1968 das protest ja die hat sich zum
fünfzigsten mal
sie waren damals schon professor berkley
einem der zentren der studentischen
protestbewegung welche erinnerungen
haben sie an diese revolution
ich habe sehr viele erinnerungen
am meisten ist mir geblieben dass unsere
revolution 1964 begann und 1968 zu ende
war
danach hatte die radikale bewegung
keinen einfluss mehr auf unsere
universität in europa begann die
revolution viel später in berkeley war
sie 1968 vorbei wie fast überall wurde
dann aus dem ursprünglichen idealismus
radikalismus der in eine art nihilismus
mündete deshalb musste an den
universitäten irgendwie die kontrolle
wieder hergestellt werden was viel
schwieriger war als die lancierung der
revolution
das weiß ich weil ich an beiden
beteiligt war
gegen revolutionen sind immer
schwieriger als revolutionen aber für
den erfolg revolutionäre ideale ist es
wichtig dass die revolutionäre bewegung
besiegt wird das braucht er in berkeley
zeit und viel erfahren sie waren ja
selbst hat dieses idealismus sie waren
zum beispiel teil der free speech
bewegung das haben wir uns ja worum ging
es da eigentlich
ursprünglich ging es um redefreiheit
die universität verbot uns
protestbewegungen und protest
vorlesungen auf dem campus zu ordern ist
das war eine ernsthafte verletzung die
redefreiheit und ich tat was ich konnte
damit uns dieses recht an der
universität wieder gewährt wurde
schließlich gelang uns das auch aber es
war ein enormer kraftakt
wir mussten den kanzler entlassen und
die universität für kurze zeit schließen
es war alles andere als einfach
und es war damals tatsächlich so eine
art funke der weltweit dann zu einem
flächenbrand an den universitäten führte
was mich interessiert ist free speech
die freie rede das recht der freiheit
ist auch heute wieder an den
amerikanischen universitäten ein
riesiges thema das hat sich verändert im
vergleich zu damals die redefreiheit ist
wir macht habe immer eine gefahr und oft
auch für leute die an die macht kommen
wollen
heute werden deshalb gewisse ideen
verboten
doch solche verbote sind immer
gefährlich man sollte ideen nicht
verbieten
trotzdem wird es gemacht meinungen wie
frauen sollten eine andere rolle in der
gesellschaft spielen als männer will man
zum beispiel verbieten
man muss daher immer wieder für die
redefreiheit kämpfen und die linke ist
so sehr dagegen wie die rechte viele
vertreter des linken lagers können das
nur schwer verstehen aber es stimmt es
wird nie einen endgültigen sieg für die
redefreiheit geben aber wir werden den
jetzigen kampf gewinnen wie wir den
letzten gewonnen haben die us amerikaner
haben das glück dass ihre verfassung das
recht auf redefreiheit garantiert
philosophisch ist das ein dummes
argument aber in der politik ist es
wichtig sagen zu können dass etwas ein
von der verfassung garantiertes recht
verletzt als philosoph hat man sich wozu
braucht es dieses recht aber die meisten
amerikaner finden man müsse nur
argumentieren dagegen verstößt die
verletzung die redefreiheit gegen den
ersten zusatzartikel unserer verfassung
eine verfassung hat also ihre vorteile
auch wenn sie philosophisch gesehen
idiotisch ist so sie haben das schon
gesagt
freie rede dass es ein problem dass von
der linken in den 60er jahren an den
campus getragen würde heute könnte man
sagen es hat sich geändert es ist eher
etwas worum die politische rechte kämpft
kann man sagen da gab es so einen einen
wechsel der seiten
ich denke dass wechselt ständig die
meisten sind für redefreiheit solange
sie die äußerung der eigenen ideen dient
sobald es um die ideen anderer geht sind
sie weniger dafür vor allem wenn sie
diese idee nicht befürworten daher
müssen wir wie gesagt ständig um diese
freiheit kämpfen
und wenn wir dieses recht nicht auch
leuten zu bestehen deren ideen uns
zuwider sind befürworten wir die
redefreiheit nicht voll und ganz das ist
das problem
dieses recht gilt auch für leute die
ihren ansichten wir verabscheuen
sie sagten auch diese phase des
idealismus mit der revolution muss
irgendwie reguliert werden er muss
einhalt gebieten will boden werden in
kalifornien so dass es die geburtsstunde
von ronald reagan war es kam dann die
nixen er
sehen sie da parallelen zu der heutigen
lage mit dem phänomen
schwer zu sagen
diese probleme gab es schon vorkommen
sein sieg war erstaunlich für uns alle
doch das schätzen die meisten
intellektuellen falsch ein
denn sie meinten große ereignisse
müssten die wichtige ursachen haben
die wahl von kramp war ein großes
ereignis hatte aber geringe ursachen ein
paar tausend stimmen und ein paar
starken fehlten sonst wäre hillary
clinton heute präsidentin der usa
ein zufall verhalf ihm zum sieg ein paar
kleine änderungen im wahlsystem hätten
genügt und er wäre nicht gewählt worden
die wahl von kramp hat er eine große
wirkung ist aber kein großes soziales
ereignis sie ändert unser land nicht
übrigens waren alle trams walser eine
katastrophe er ist jetzt seit 1
ja im amt aber mein leben ist noch
ziemlich gleich wie vor treibt das ist
das geniale an der us-verfassung die
gewählten macht vertreter können nicht
viel anrichten
also es gibt eine hohe resilienz auch in
der amerikanischen demokratie
andererseits gibt es menschen in amerika
auch außerhalb von amerika die sagen das
phänomen trump ist schon ein bisschen
was anderes konstitutionelle rechte
verfassungsrechte sind mit ihm und
seiner person in anderer weise bedroht
gut möglich dass er systematisch
konstitutionelle rechte angreifen wird
aber daran zweifel aus ich habe den
eindruck es ist ihm egal
er hat kein programm amerikas
gründerväter hatten angst vor typen wie
trump aber am meisten litten sie männer
wie napoleon oder caesar machthaber mit
einem plan dafür strump zu dumm
er lebt von einem tag zum anderen und
hat bis jetzt keinen schaden angerichtet
vielleicht wird er das noch tun aber bis
jetzt hatte die verfassungsrechte nicht
gefährdet deren verfasser hatten die
brillante idee dafür zu sorgen dass
keine typen wie napoleon cäsar oder
trump die macht an sich reißen und das
land zerstören können
und es ist nie passiert ist sehr
interessant was sie sagen ich wäre
besorgt wenn tram kein ideologe wäre
aber da überhaupt keine ideologie hat
mache ich mir auch gar keine großen
sorgen ist das ist dass ihre einstellung
dazu
ich weiß nicht ob wir unbesorgt sein
können
gut möglich dass ein schusseliger
opportun ist gleich viel schaden
anrichten kann wie ein ideologe oder
ideologen wie lenin oder hitler haben
einen plan
sie wissen was wir eine gesellschaft sie
errichten wollen und welchen schaden sie
weltweit anrichten können hat keinen
plan und sollte ihr diese woche einen
haben hatte ihn wahrscheinlich nächste
woche vergessen
bis jetzt hat ihr sehr wenig schaden
angerichtet mein leben ist praktisch
gleich wie es unter barack obama war
obwohl dieser eine völlig andere
philosophie vertrag
dank unserer verfassung können
gefährliche präsidenten nicht viel
schaden anrichten
das ist ja an sich sehr erfreulich sie
haben jetzt sehr politisch gesprochen
allerseits kann man sagen sie sind gar
kein politischer philosoph sondern sind
ein versuch der sprache und des geistes
und 69 ist auch etwas anderes passiert
sie haben ein buch geschrieben das zu
den ganz wenigen großen kanonischen
büchern der philosophie des 20
jahrhunderts zählt sprechakte speech als
auf englisch
das ist die grundidee hinter diesem buch
die grundsätzliche idee ist folgende in
der geschichte der sprachforschung ging
man davon aus dass strache aussetzen
besteht und diese bekämen ihre bedeutung
weil die worte für vorstellungen stehen
wir meinen mann verstehe den satz weil
einem bilder durch den kopf gehen
richtig aber die große idee der sprecher
theorie ist sprache nicht als etwas
fixes zu beurteilen sondern als etwas
was menschen tun
wichtig ist der sprecher
ich spreche und sie verstehen mich sie
sprechen und ich verstehe sie
das betrifft das geschriebene wie das
gesprochene wort und ist eine neue
ausgangslage für die erforschung der
sprache denn man beachtet nicht länger
die bilder im kopf sondern fragt sich
was tun die menschen wenn sie sprechen
wie verhalten sie sich darum geht es im
buch sprechakte doch als ich es schrieb
war ich noch ein kind aber in der
philosophie ist man mit 35 noch ein kind
eigentlich schrieb ich es früher
ich wurde abgelenkt von dem fuß pietsch
bewegung ich hatte es ende 1963 oder 64
fertig geschrieben
da ich aber mit der revolution
beschäftigt war verzögerte sich die
veröffentlichung um ihre royale solche
dinge passieren nun mal im leben
es ist doch interessant dass man sagt
ich war eigentlich schon fertig mit dem
buch dann muss ich aber erst mal
politisch aktiv werden und dann waren
sie professor berkley kann ich die
grundidee von sprechakte vielleicht doch
mal zu reformieren die philosophen haben
über sprache etwas als etwas nachgedacht
dass die wirklichkeit abbildet und sie
haben gesagt dass es etwas was die
wirklichkeit
verändert etwas was wir tun mit dem wir
neue fakten schaffen
das ist eine wunderbare idee und
implizit sowohl bei john austin als auch
bei ludwig wittgenstein vorhanden
ich habe es nur thematisiert nicht
erfunden austin war mein lehrer und
wittgenstein hat mich inspiriert ich
habe ihn nie kennengelernt er war
bereits tot als ich von ihm hervor
wie auch immer die beiden meinten wir
sollten sprache als etwas betrachten was
leute tun
das ist ein riesiger unterschied unter
anderem aus den gründen die sie vorhin
genannt haben die sprache beschreibt
nicht nur die wirklichkeit oft verändert
sie diese wir können die sprache nutzen
um eine neue wirklichkeit zu erfinden
darüber habe ich einiges geschrieben was
wir als institutionelle realität
bezeichnung geld eigentum regierungen
heirat fernsehsender cocktailpartys
sommerferien sind alles sprachliche
kreationen wie funktioniert das
eine faszinierende frage ich habe zwei
bücher darüber geschrieben und wenn erst
am anfang hat man sieht auch wie sie das
immer noch bewegt man zum beispiel ein
beispiel nehmen wo man sagt da wird das
relativ klar
das bewegt mich immer noch das hört nie
auf wenn ihr in der sache ein beispiel
dass sie wählen das sehr bekannt
geworden ist zum beispiel das taufen
der auftakt ist nicht nur ein satz der
etwas beschreibt sondern ergibt einen
namen er schafft eine neue soziale
realität und würden sie sagen dass das
ein sehr rege geleitetes verhalten ist
dass sich diese regeln beschreiben
lassen ja wie man jemanden taucht auf
jeden fall und das ziel der sprecher
theorie ist es die regeln zu beschreiben
aufgrund derer wir sprechakte ausführen
wir haben etwas faszinierendes
festgestellt es gibt zwei arten von
regeln viele regeln regulieren
die die regel auf der rechten
straßenseite zu fahren in der schweiz
und in deutschland liest man häufig das
ist verboten andere regeln regulieren
nicht nur das leben sie schaffen neue
verhaltensformen die regeln die
festlegen was zu einer taufe einer
abstimmung oder eine heirat gehört dies
sind konstitutive regeln sie schaffen
eine neue realität
die nur existiert weil es handlungen
gibt die mit den regeln übereinstimmen
ich versuche das doch mal zusammen
es gibt zwei arten von den regeln die
anders sein könnten
oder regeln die nicht anders sein können
ohne alles zu verändern
nicht ganz es gibt regeln die bereits
existierende verhaltensformen regulieren
sie können rechts oder links fahren das
ist die regulierung eines bereits
existierenden verhaltens es gibt aber
regeln die nicht nur etwas regulieren
sondern das verhalten das sie regulieren
zugleich erschaffen und ich argumentiere
dass die regeln der sprache so sind wenn
wir also englisch oder deutsch sprechen
oder so ein gespräch führen agieren wir
aufgrund gewisser konstitutive regeln
ich finde das ist ein faszinierendes
forschungsgebiet ich könnte mich mehrere
leben lang damit befassen obwohl ich
schon viel arbeit hineingesteckt habe
und ihre große these war nicht nur zu
sagen dass sprache in gewisser weise
handeln ist sondern dass sie auch
versuchen aus zu buchstabieren gleichsam
wie diese regeln zu verstehen sind und
was diese regeln sind und sie sagten
auch sprache schafft mögen wir eine art
von realität es gibt ja zwei arten von
realitäten ich will ihn mal ein beispiel
wenn ein herz der war ist heißt dass
dieser schein 10 franken war wert ist
ein anderer satzes in diesem glas ist
wasser diese sätze sind nicht in
gleicher weise war weil dieser satz ist
war ganz unabhängig davon was wir
glauben dieser satz ist nur war das denn
wir auch daran glauben
richtig das ist absolut faszinierend
mittels der sprache schaffen wir eine
realität die nur existiert weil wir an
ihre existenz glauben das ist sehr
wichtig richtig es hört sich an wie
fiktion aber wenn genügend leute daran
glauben funktioniert es ich befinde mich
momentan in der schweiz
ich lebe in den usa ich bin us-bürger
und professor in berkeley
ich beteilige mich an den wahlen in
meinem land und ich bin mitglied der
demokratischen partei all das sind
realitäten die nur existieren weil
genügend menschen daran glauben durch
ihren glauben daran schaffen sie deren
existenz
das trifft nicht auf die schwerkraft den
magnetismus das wasser und die
bewegungen der planeten zu aber geld
eigentum heirat regierungen und sprachen
existieren nur weil menschen an deren
existenz glauben und entsprechend
handeln faszinierend sagen wir mal alle
menschen auf dieser erde glauben dass
der mond aus hüttenkäse besteht und das
wäre dann eine realität wir und das wäre
falsch
wie unterscheidet man sagen eine
kollektive illusion die funktional
wirksam ist wie gelder von einem
wirklichen irrtum jetzt argumentieren
sie wie ein philosoph
das ist eine schöne philosophische frage
im ansatz lautet die antwort so es gibt
eine kategorie von tatsachen die wir
durch sprache erschaffen und wir tun das
weil diese tatsachen aus kollektiv
akzeptierten machtbefugnissen bestehen
weil wir dadurch macht schaffen
es gibt positive machtbefugnisse die
rechte und negative wie pflichten die
positive macht die einem 10 franken
schein gegeben wird ist die macht damit
dinge kaufen zu können
diese macht haben sie als besitzer des
geldscheins solche machtbefugnisse
schaffen wir einfach indem wir
übereinkommen dass sie existieren
wie ist das möglich wie kommt es dass
eine gewisse macht nur existiert weil
wir an ihre existenz glauben es ist eine
spezielle form von macht ich nenne sie
den tisch gemacht rechte pflichten
vorschriften berechtigungen erlaubnisse
das ist von griechischen begriff für
pflicht diese theoretische macht
funktioniert wenn die menschen sie
akzeptieren ich musste heute ein
formular ausfüllen ein unglaublich
langweiliges formular
wie sich herausstellt ist inzwischen
auch die schweiz von einkommensteuern
besessen arme schweizer jahre lang war
ihnen das egal
es ist ein skandal
aber sie schaffen eine institutionelle
tatsache aufgrund derer ich ein
unschuldiger us-bürger ein paar franken
einkommen steuern bezahlen muss das ist
lächerlich
wie auch immer so werden machtbefugnisse
geschaffen die nur existieren weil die
menschen daran glauben
dadurch werden ihre muskeln aber nicht
kräftiger und ihr auto nicht schneller
es werden nur mehr rechte pflichten
genehmigungen vorschriften und so weiter
geschaffen
warum weil all das sich in die
menschliche rationalität einschleust und
handlungs gründe kreiert die nicht von
unseren bedürfnissen abhängen
wenn ich also zu etwas verpflichtet bin
habe ich einen grund es zu tun
unabhängig von einem wünschen und das
ist der schlüssel zum verständnis der
menschlichen zivilisation habe ich kurz
da gleich nachbarn es gibt ja auch dinge
bei denen wir uns gar nicht so sicher
sind auch die philosophen nicht ob sie
jetzt fiktionen sind oder nicht zum
beispiel die menschen erste oder ein
satz wie soll es keinen unschuldigen
töten
ja was will ihnen sagen
die menschenrechte sind real aber nicht
so real wie unsere daumen menschenrechte
muss man rechtfertigen damit sie als
solche anerkannt werden menschenrechte
gehören zur klasse der institutionellen
tatsachen wie geld eigentum regierungen
und heirat sie funktionieren nur weil
menschen an ihrer existenz glauben was
aber nicht heißt dass dieser glaube
unbegründet wäre oder nicht von anderen
geteilt würde es gibt gründe warum
menschenrechte geschaffen werden und es
ist die aufgabe des philosophen diese
gründe zu spezifizieren
dafür braucht es meiner meinung nach
zwei dinge man braucht eine vorstellung
davon was den menschen ausmacht und was
es braucht damit er sich entwickeln kann
menschen können sich nur entwickeln wenn
sie sprechen sich mitteilen können
daher der anspruch auf redefreiheit
desweiteren braucht ist das was die
philosophen archäologen nennen eine
werte lehre die unterscheidet was
wichtig und was unwichtig ist was
unbedeutend und was ernstzunehmend ist
zu sprechen ist wichtiger für das
menschsein als sich am kopf zu kratzen
man braucht also zwei dinge um die
menschenrechte zu begründen die beide
altmodisch sind eine theorie der
menschlichen natur und eine theorie der
menschlichen werte damit können sie die
menschenrechte rechtfertigen eine große
antwort auf die frage was er mensch die
auch wittgenstein gegeben hat ist der
mensch ist ein sprechendes lesen die
sprache ist das fundament unserer
lebensform sie haben ein leben damit
euer 8 zu deuten und zu erkennen wie
komplex das eigentlich ist ich will ein
beispiel geben wie komplex das ist wenn
ich sage was sie sagen es wahnsinnig
instanz ich habe es gerade noch
verstanden
dann klingt das wie eine beschreibung
aber es hat auch etwas impliziert indem
man sagt ich habe noch mehr gesagt als
ich eigentlich sagen würde die wenig
sein
schlechte luft hier das würde heißen
machen sie doch mal das fenster ich
hab's nicht gesagt aber sein platzierter
ein wahnsinnig komplizierter vorgang in
jeder gesprächssituation wird mehr
impliziert als wirklich gesagt sprache
funktioniert nur wenn wir diese
implikationen verstehen also über das
hinausgehen können was gesagt wird
wenn sie mit mir sprechen müssen sie
nicht sagen bitte beantworten sie die
frage oder fahren sie weiter
denn das impliziert die art unserer
diskussion
sie haben also recht was gesagt wird in
einer unterhaltung ist nur die spitze
des eisbergs sehr viel wird
vorausgesetzt
ich nenne das den hintergrund jeder von
uns bringt zu diesem gespräch ein
hintergrundwissen mit ein problem in
fremden ländern ist dass man kein
hintergrundwissen hat
in den usa überquert jeder die straße wo
er will
in gewissen deutschen gemeinden hingegen
ist es polizeilich verboten die straße
bei rot zu überqueren eine sehr
germanische haltung ich denke da zeigen
sich kulturelle unterschiede
nun gibt es eine bestimmte spezies
sprechender dinge die mit diesem
background wie sie sagen im hintergrund
oder dem eisberg ein wunderbares wäre
unglaublich große probleme haben und das
sind socken der entsprechende maschinen
die kommune diesen implizieren was
eigentlich gemeint ist nicht erreicht
woran liegt das
sprechende maschinen sprechen nicht
wirklich zumindest nicht die heutigen
computer die kein bewusstsein haben sie
geben laute von sich und wir
programmieren sie so dass sie richtig
klingen sie können auch nicht adäquat
reagieren auf das was auf die auf den
bau laut sie können nicht denken und
ohne gedanken gibt es keine sprache denn
wir sprechen ist ausdruck von gedanken
wir haben maschinen erfunden die das
sprechen simulieren können aber sie
sprechen nicht sicher sind sie nützlich
aber es ist ein philosophischer fehler
zu meinen wir hätten denkende computer
geschaffen
dafür müsste man computer mit
bewusstsein bauen können aber das ist
noch nicht gelungen
ihr vergleich dazu kommen es gibt jetzt
lang zwei dinge darüber zu ja es gibt
einen test der heißt der turing test ein
sehr berühmter test in der philosophie
des zweiten jahrhunderts der heißt im
prinzip wenn da eine scheibe ist und ich
sehe dich die scheibe nicht durch und
ich habe das gefühl dass derjenige der
mir gegenüber sitzt genau so antwortet
die sie mir jetzt antworten würden und
ich kann das nicht unterscheiden und auf
der anderen seite sitzt ein computer
dann kann dieser computer sprechen und
hat das bewusstsein
jetzt gibt es zumindest eine tatsache es
gibt noch gar keine maschine die
wirklich ein gespräch führen kann wenn
das alles so regel geleitet ist warum
eigentlich nicht
ich sehe keinen grund warum wir nicht
eine maschine bauen könnten die unser
verhalten perfekt imitieren also sich an
einem gespräch beteiligen kann
falsch wäre es zu behaupten maschinen
könnten denken hätten eine eigene
meinung oder würden einen wirklich
verstehen warum nicht
weil sie kein bewusstsein haben ohne
bewusstsein kann man all dies nicht
anders wäre es wenn wir eine bewusste
maschine schaffen könnten
aber davon sind wir weit entfernt
heutige computer haben kein bewusstsein
also können sie nicht denken oder
verstehen und haben auch keine anderen
kognitiven fähigkeiten
schauen wir uns mal das beispiel eines
science-fiction-films an in dem
behauptet wird
solche maschinen gibt der film heißt
höher wir sehen den keller und die regie
für das erste intelligente operating
system der welt heißt sie herzlich
willkommen wir würden ihn gern ein paar
fragen stellen
okay sind sie gesellig oder ungesellig
ich denke ich bin seit einer weile
ungesellig wie würden sie ihr verhältnis
zu ihrer mutter beschreiben
vielen dank bitte warten sie ihr
operating system wird gestartet
hallo da bin ich hey ich bin momentan
[Musik]
guten morgen du hast in fünf minuten ein
meeting bist du vielleicht versuchen
aufzustehen durchdrückt okay gut ich bin
lustig ich möchte alles lernen über
alles ich liebe die art wie die welt sie
ist
dann bist du wieder bereit für ein date
meinst du dass ich weiß aus deinen e
mails dass du eine trennung hinter dir
hast also neugierig bist du gar nicht
wie war's doch verheiratet zu sein es
ist irgendwie ein gutes gefühl sein
leben mit jemandem zu teilen
wie teilt man sein leben mit jemandem
[Musik]
wie geht's dir ich glaube ich habe
gerade richtig viel spaß ich finde das
hast du verdient
es ist lange her dass ich mit jemanden
zusammen war in dessen gegenwart ich
mich so gut gefühlt habe
[Musik]
ich erkläre das ganz kurz das ist ein
operating system das man kaufen kann und
mit dem dieser menschen eine beziehung
eine liebesbeziehung eingeht aber es
geht noch weiter in dem film dieses
system entwickelt ein eigenes
bewusstsein dass die menschlichen weit
überlegen ist und dann kommt es zu einer
art kommunikations abbruch weil er
mensch zu langweilig geworden ist kann
das auch sein dass die maschinen uns
nicht nur kopieren sondern weit
überflügeln werden wenn wir das was das
gehirn leistet künstlich erzeugen
könnten nämlich eine maschine mit
bewusstsein auszustatten wäre das
philosophisch interessant da heutige
computer kein bewusstsein haben sind sie
uninteressant
eine maschine wird definiert aufgrund
der symbole die sie manipuliert
ursprünglich waren das nullen und einsen
vorjahren wie sich die vorstellung dass
solche maschinen bewusstsein haben
können weit von mir mit einem argument
das so einfach ist dass ich mich schäme
es ist das gedankenexperiment
chinesischer raum
wir werden dieses zu den berühmtesten
gedankenexperimente dafür sowie des 20
jahrhunderts zählt einmal nach stehen
erstmal kurz dort die anderen es geht
wenn ich einen fehler mache staubig das
ist ein normaler krise der chinesisch
spricht der reicht über schriftzeichen
erfragen oder und geschichten weitern
eine person wie wir beide die nicht
chinesisch spricht und dann passiert
folgendes diese person in diesem raum
der chinesischen raum heißt das in dem
gedanken im moment hat eine chinesische
grammatik und hat schriftzeichen spricht
aber selbst kein chinesisch was er aber
kann ist aufgrund der zeichen die er
sieht zurückgehen und seen sprache
regeln zeichen und so tun als ob er da
eine antwort gibt und erreicht sich
hinaus und er macht das die ganze zeit
so dass diese person hat der chinese
glauben muss der da drin steht
chinesisch dabei versteht ja überhaupt
nichts weiß nicht worüber er redet
richtig im ursprünglichen beispiel bin
ich diese person
ich kann also nicht davon ausgehen dass
sie vielleicht chinesisch spricht denn
ich weiß dass ich das nicht kann
dass sich die fragen richtig beantworten
könnte beweist nicht dass die chinesisch
sprechen kann
sie wissen worauf das experiment hinaus
will genau das tut ein computer er
schiebt symbole hin und her und gibt so
antworten passend zu den ihm gestellten
fragen
aber er versteht nichts er ist wie ich
im chinesischen raum
ich bekomme die chinesischen symbole als
input ich liefere chinesische symbole
als output wenn ich die regeln richtig
an wände bestehe ich den turing test in
sie erwähnt haben
ich kann einen muttersprachler täuschen
gemeint ich könnte chinesisch aber ich
verstehe kein wort chinesisch und das
argument ist so gewichtig weil ich die
testperson bin es ist nicht eine
maschine ich bin in diesem zimmer wäre
seine maschine könnte ich meinen sie
verstünde das gesagte von mir weiß ich
aber dass ich kein wort chinesisch
verstehe warum nicht weil ich den
chinesischen symbolen keine bedeutung
zuordnen kann
das ist das geheimnis des computers hier
muss keine bedeutung zu ordnen
er verfügt nicht über eine semantik
sondern über das was linguisten syntax
nennen
er speichert symbole ohne zu wissen was
sie bedeuten das ist keine schwäche des
computers sondern eine stärke er muss
sich nicht darum kümmern was er denkt
habe ich das vielleicht rekapitulieren
dh wenn ich diese person wäre in dem
raum ich könnte so tun als ob ich
antworte ich weiß aber gar nicht worüber
ich spreche worum es geht man kann sagen
sie nennen das intentional i tät wenn
ich das richtig verstehe er baut man hat
keine ahnung worum es geht man tut
einfach so in dem ein zeichen
austauschen
ich habe keine ahnung und sie sagen
computer sind genau solche maschinen die
haben keine ahnung
die stärke des computers ist dass ihr
nicht weiß was etwas bedeutet und er
muss es auch nicht können
er verfügt über eine syntax er hortet
symbole aber nicht wieder eine semantik
kann also deren bedeutung nicht erfassen
sein job ist die symbole zu speichern
ein leistungsstarker computer denen sie
richtig programmieren kann ihnen
vortäuschen er habe sie verstanden aber
er versteht rein gar nichts
per definition denn er ist nur eine
syntaktische maschine
er ersetzt symbole durch andere mehr
nicht
wenn es klagt wie eine ente und es
schwimmt wie eine ente naja dann nennen
wir seine eltern man könnte ja sagen
wenn es so spricht wie ein mensch wenn
es sich so verhält wie ein mensch wenn
es so handelt die ein mensch dann hat es
doch wahrscheinlich nein das hat sie
nicht ich weiß nicht ob ich das beispiel
mit der ente akzeptieren soll eine
künstliche ente kann sich wie eine ente
verhalten ohne eine ente zu sein aber
dieser maschine versteht ja per
definition nichts weil sie ein computer
ist computer wurden von allen tuning und
anderen informatikern aufgrund ihrer
leistungen definiert nämlich einfachen
manipulationen von nullen und einsen
jedes binärsystem täters das ist die
stärke nicht die schwäche des computers
er ist eine syntaktische maschine
er hat per definition keine meinung das
ist ein groß ist ein wichtiges argument
und ist doch ein prophetisches argument
sie haben das neue ersonnen und es ist
immer noch ein aktuelles argument bevor
wirklich die maschinen so leistungsfähig
waren wie sie jetzt sind
aber es gibt ein problem in der
philosophie des geistes das kennen sie
auch sie haben nur zugang zu ihrem
bewusstsein und ich habe jetzt erst mal
nur zu einem woher weiß ich denn dass
sie nicht so eine maschine sind gut sie
sind wirklich philosoph ich weiß dass
sie keine solche maschine sind weil ich
zusammen mit anderen menschen in einer
zivilisation lebe ich setze mich täglich
mit ihnen auseinander und sehe dass sie
ähnliche mechanismen haben wie ich ich
veranschauliche das mit einem anderen
beispiel ich habe einen wunderbaren
berner sennen und er heißt fast meinen
hunden gebe ich die namen von
philosophen frege russell ludwig und
tasci sind sehr intelligent ich hege
keinen zweifel dass tasci ein
bewusstsein hat das ist eindeutig seine
gehirnstruktur und sein verhalten legen
das nahe
es wäre denkbar dass er eine klug
ersonnene maschine ist die nicht täuscht
aber das ist eigentlich unmöglich es ist
nur die künstliche zweifel eines
skeptischen philosoph ähnlich ist es mit
den menschen denen ich auf der straße
begegnet vielleicht stellt sich heraus
dass darunter ein programmierter roboter
ist aber sie und die anderen menschen
denen ich heute begegnet benutzern mit
denen ich täglich zu tun haben können
unmöglich roboter seien von schlechter
skeptizismus ein schlechter zweifel weil
er gar nicht wahrhaftig sein kann
andererseits ist es doch so ist kommt
das was sie bewusst sein denn oder was
man bewusst sein es ist eine
komplizierte sache es kommt in
verschiedenen stufen ja wir mal an ich
trinke jetzt dieses glas wasser ich habe
dieses ganz eigenartige gefühl wasser zu
trinken
das hätte ich auch wenn keine erdbeere
es wert wäre würden sie sagen dass das
schon bewusstsein ist und dass das schon
etwas ist was maschine haben können
zweifellos wasser trinken und erdbeeren
essen ist etwas bewusst ist wo wir
bräuchten wie erdbeeren wenn wir kein
bewusstsein hätten dafür sind sie
definitiv zu teuer
auch wasser sie trinken wasser um ihren
durst zu löschen
das ist ein bewusster prozess die
schlüssel zum verständnis von all dem
ist das bewusstsein philosophen
widerstrebt das weil sie denken wenn man
über das bewusstsein spricht landet man
bei descartes bei der seele und der
unsterblichkeit
ich finde wir sollten das bewusstsein
wie die verdauung als ein normales
biologisches phänomen betrachten das
bewusstsein ist für das gehirn wie die
verdauung für den magen und den
restlichen verdauungstrakt es geschieht
einfach aber es ist wesentlich für unser
mentales leben der ohne bewusstsein gibt
es kein denken und fühlen es wäre nur
simulation nichts reales und real ist
alles auch unbewusst ist das bewusst
wären aber wenn ihre mitbürger in der
nähe von berkeley
vielleicht das schaffen sagen wir mal
einen computer mit einer biomasse
anzuschließen oder vielleicht sogar mit
einem organismus der dann in der lage
ist zb wasser aufzunehmen oder eine
erdbeere zu essen und der dann sagen
würde
erdbeere und es wäre immer noch keine
biologische struktur sondern sagen wir
mal eine silikon struktur hintern immer
noch sagen auf keinen fall wenn sie eine
maschine konstruieren können die
bewerkstelligt was das gehirn kann haben
sie eine denken der maschine einen
künstlichen menschen geschaffen
wir wissen aber nicht wie wir das
anstellen sollen
weil wir nicht wissen wie das gehirn
bewusstsein generiert vielleicht stellt
sich heraus dass es für die schaffung
von bewusstsein keine nucleus proteine
braucht man könnte es so formulieren
wir können in eine maschine herstellen
die ohne federn oder flügel fliegen kann
aber sie muss so leistungsstark sein
dass sie die schwerkraft die erde und
der atmosphäre überwinden kann
sie muss kein vogel sein aber sie muss
über die flugfähigkeit von vögeln finden
gleichermaßen muss eine bewusste
maschine kein mensch sein aber sie muss
die fähigkeiten des menschlichen und
tierischen gehirns kopieren um dieses
bewusstsein zu haben
sie muss über kausale mechanismen
verfügen die vergleichbare leistungen
bringen auch so fixiert waren es
vielleicht die große frage der zukunft
ist die große frage der menschheit
selbst in bezug zu den maschinen sie
sagen wenn es das schaffen könnte was
das menschliche gehirn leistet nämlich
bewusstsein zu schaffen
da kann man ja sagen da gibt es auch
eine erklärung lücke das wäre ein gutes
kriterium wenn wir wüssten wie das
gehirn eigentlich bewusstsein erzeugt
aber wir wissen es ja gar nicht
ja wir wissen es nicht wir wissen nicht
wie das gehirn bewusstsein erzeugt also
können wir keine denken der maschine
erfinden wir wissen die vögel fliegen
wir können maschinen herstellen die
fliegen ohne mit den flügeln zu schlagen
nachdem der 0-prinzip wenn wir also
wissen wie wir bewusst sein
schaffen können wir vielleicht eine
maschine mit bewusstsein bauen aber wir
haben keine ahnung wie das gehirn
bewusstsein erzeugt also können wir es
auch nicht künstlich erzeugen
haben sie denn eine ahnung wie ein
organismus in der evolution entstanden
ist der von etwas was unbewusst war
diesen riesensprung diesen göttlichen
sprung ins bewusstsein macht was da der
schalter rate umgestellt wurde
nun gut jetzt sprechen wir über die
evolution ein faszinierender prozess der
schon millionen jahre dauert sie begann
mit organismen die nicht mehr als
einfache schleim klumpen waren aber
diese entwickelten sich in einem sehr
komplexen prozess der aber millionen
jahre dauerte und am anderen ende kamen
wir heraus was passiert das wissen wir
nicht wir wissen einzig menschen haben
ein bewusstsein dank sehr spezifischen
zellen die neurone mit ihren aktionen
und den briten sehen neuronen ziemlich
gespenstisch aus nicht die normale
zellen dorf neuronen allein genügen
nicht wir haben ein paar millionen im
magen aber mein magen hat kein
bewusstsein und ihre auch nicht wenn sie
aber genügend neuronen in ihrem gehirn
haben und diese richtig funktionieren
schaffen sie bewusst sein
wie funktioniert das wir wissen es nicht
wir wissen nur dass es geschieht
neuronen im menschlichen und tierischen
gehirn schaffen bewusstsein wie
funktioniert das
daran arbeiten wissenschaftler die ich
bezahle warum finden sie es nicht heraus
aber diese konstellation diese
beschreiben die ist schon sehr
bemerkenswert man kann einen sagen in
einer frage die als eine große
stagnation fast seit 2500 jahren wir
wissen nicht genau was bewusstsein ist
und wir sind in dieser schlüsselfrage
nicht weitergekommen
andererseits gibt es auf seiten der
ingenieure eine unglaubliche entwicklung
in kompetenzen von denen man früher
glaubte das können der bewusste
maschinen bewusste lesen tun
heißt wir sind hier praktisch an einem
punkt an dem wir gar nicht weiter kommen
und die andere entwickelt sich
exponentiell schnell das heißt doch auch
dass die philosophie ein bisschen
machtlos und ratlos da steht die
ingenieure wechseln einfach das thema
sie versuchen gar nicht eine maschine
mit bewusstsein zu entwickeln da sie
nicht wissen wie das gehirn bewusstsein
schafft können sie es nicht imitieren
also versuchen sie die stärken des
bewusstseins zu simulieren
damit die maschinen den touring test
bestehen das ist schön und gut
wir benutzen ständig computer dagegen
habe ich nichts aber sie sollten nicht
glauben sie würden eine bewusste
maschine brauchen eine maschine welche
die richtigen antworten auf die
richtigen fragen gibt verfügt noch lange
nicht über bewusstsein
sonst könnte sie die fähigkeiten
mysteriums verdoppeln
wir wissen aber nicht wie wir das
hinkriegen und niemand versucht es
herauszufinden
man versucht nur maschinen zu bauen die
den turing test bestehen das ist
bestimmt nützlich ich habe selbst so
einer maschine einen landtag aber er hat
kein bewusstsein und die informatiker
die ihn bauten versuchten nicht ihn mit
bewusstsein auszustatten
denn sie hatten nicht die geringste
ahnung wie im zentrum einer zentrum der
innovation über die über die bucht
hinweg ist das silicon valley
da sind die schlimmsten und schärfsten
geister dieser werde damit beschäftigt
genau das tun von dem was eingeweiht und
dann kommt da ein philosoph der schon
ein bisschen älter ist gesagt ich habe
euch schon vor 40 jahren gesagt dass das
quatsch es was immer wir reagieren diese
junge menschen sind sie mit dem in
kontakt nein was sie tun ist nicht
unsinnig finde sie leisten großartiges
das wissen sie auch und im gegensatz zu
meiner arbeit verdienen sie damit
unmengen geld aber auch mit falschen
versprechungen mit überzogenen
erwartungen
die klügeren die ich kenne sagen nicht
sie hätten bewusste maschinen gebaut
vielleicht vertreter der früheren
generation wie john mccarthy der die
künstliche intelligenz prägte
die jüngeren informatiker befinden sich
noch im chinesischen raum
sie sind gebildeter sie sagen finden wir
eine maschine die so tut als ob und wir
machen eine menge geld damit
das versuchen sie dagegen habe ich
nichts das ist gut
hoffentlich verdienen sie viel geld
damit und bauen immer bessere maschinen
aber sie sollten nicht meinen einer
maschine mit bessere rechenleistung käme
dem bewusstsein näher
sie versuchen nicht eine bewusste
maschine zu kreieren sie wüssten nicht
wie sie versuchen hardware und programme
zu entwickeln die komplexere operationen
durchführen können
es gibt aber schon versprechungen die in
diesem kulturkreis und dieser kultur
diesem milieu der praxen die betreffen
zum beispiel die unsterblichkeit so gibt
es die idee vielleicht ist es nur das
phantasma und habe mit kollegen von
ihnen gesprochen da klaus hofstetter zum
beispiel sagt naja schauen wir die idee
ist dass man die bewusstseins inhalte
die gesamte information die das ihr
gehirn jetzt hat er downloaded man weiß
nicht so richtig wie und dann im prinzip
dafür sorgt dass das was sie ausmacht
nämlich ihr geist gar nicht sterben muss
während ihr körper dann irgendwann ein
ende findet ihre idee ist auf rührende
weise schwachsinnig man nehme alle
informationen aus der
universitätsbibliothek in zürich füttere
einen computer damit und habe dann einen
computer der mehr weiß als der klügste
mensch ein computer stirbt niemals wenn
seine hardware alt wird ersetzt man sie
man macht ständig updates man macht zu
den backups für den fall dass man von
einem lastwagen überfahren wird
all das ist aus ihnen bekannten gründen
komisch und lächerlich denn der computer
verfügt nicht über ein gehirn sondern
über die simulation eines gehirns er hat
kein bewusstsein und wir haben keine
ahnung wie wir bewusstsein schaffen
können
diese versprechen sind zu um zu unsinnig
oberhaupt falsch zu sein
das wort dafür heißt auf
englisch bullshit und wir wissen warum
weil sie keine ahnung haben wie man
einen bewussten computerraum es gibt
noch ein tiefer gehendes argument das
ich bisher nicht angesprochen habe was
wir informationen nennen ist in uns
informationen sind relativ zum
beobachter die maschine besitzt keine
informationen
sie hat einzig komplexe elektronische
schaltungen mit denen wir informationen
simulieren können nehmen sie dieses
blatt darauf sind anmerkungen die
informationen enthalten
aber diese anmerkungen und die im
computer gespeicherten informationen
sind immer abhängig von beobachtern
abhängig von uns ich habe wesentliche
informationen gespeichert
ich weiß wie ich von berkeley nach
sandro see gelangen auch karten und das
gps vermitteln diese information aber es
ist keine richtige information sondern
etwas das abhängig ist vom beobachter
etwas das wir benutzen können
information ist also etwas zwiespältig
einerseits etwas psychologisches dass
beim denken stattfindet andererseits
etwas das abhängig ist vom betrachter an
dieser zwiespältigkeit ist nichts falsch
man darf sich einfach nicht davon
verwirren lassen
es ist fantastisch mit die man zu
sprechen derzeit wie man durch
begriffliche unterscheidungen gewisse
hoffnungen träume oder versprechungen
einfach entlarvt und das ist ein kleiner
tanz ein kleiner move und man weiß
eigentlich dass unser das muss unsinn
allein darf sich davon nicht täuschen
lassen es gibt aber natürlich und das
sieht man ja bei ihnen auch sie sind
sehr wissenschaftlicher ein sehr down to
earth also ein grundierter mensch der
sind nicht so metaphysisch aber es gibt
natürlich eine frage die da immer noch
im raum steht sagen wir mal unser
gesamtes hören ist kausal beschlossen
das sind passieren dinge nacheinander
und da gibt es aber etwas was man den
menschen zumutet ist dass die freiheit
haben
wie würden sie sagen dass das
bewusstsein dass wir haben freiheit
kreiert ist das irgendwie ein ausbruch
aus den großen ketten der welt und das
ist was anderes oder seine illusionen
das ist ein problem wir haben keine
lösung für das problem des freien
willens das problem verschwindet weil
wir alle die erfahrung von frei
kennen ich kann meinen rechten arm oder
meinem linken kaum hochheben
das ist eine freie handlung also bin
zutiefst davon überzeugt sie hänge von
mir ab aber es könnte auch sein dass sie
von einer reihe kausale zusammenhänge
ausgelöst wird sie auf eine zeit weit
vor meiner geburt zurückgeht
demnach wäre bereits als das buch der
geschichte geschrieben wurde entschieden
ob man den rechten oder den linken abend
hebt wir wissen nicht wie das gehirn
funktioniert also wissen wir auch nicht
ob wir einen freien willen haben oder
nicht
wir haben die illusion diesen oder
diesen arm zu heben sei ein freier
willensakt aber diese erfahrung des
freien willens der realität entspricht
wissen wir nicht wir müssen wissen wie
das gehirn funktioniert um
herauszufinden ob wir einen freien
willen haben wir haben den festen
eindruck des freien willens aber ob er
stimmt weiß niemand denn existenziell
lieber weil es ist ja ganz interessant
einerseits ist es sehr entlastend
jährigen alles was passiert muss
passiert ja eine form von faschisten
andererseits ist es sehr verführerisch
zu sagen ich bin wirklich frei sie als
person wenn sie sich auf eine seite
werfen müssten was würden denn lieber
aus freien willen zu handeln macht viel
spaß
es ist aber auch nervig der mann muss
verantwortung übernehmen und die älter
man wird desto mühsamer wird das mein
gott ich bin verantwortlich für all die
schrecklichen dinge die ich vor jahren
getan haben weil sie damals nicht ernst
genommen haben freien willen zu haben
bedingt dass man verantwortung übernimmt
aber ich finde es macht unglaublich spaß
ich hoffe daher dass wir tatsächlich
über freien willen verfügen und sich
nicht das falsch herausstellt es gibt
keine argumente
nein das einzige argument ist dass wir
ohne überzeugung einen freien willen zu
haben nicht handeln können aber das ist
kein argument sondern sagt etwas über
unsere psychologie aus das beweist nicht
dass wir wirklich freien willen haben
vielleicht liegen wir falsch und es
stellt sich heraus dass alles von grund
auf vorbestimmt ist wir wissen es nicht
wir müssen verstehen wie das gehirn
funktioniert und das wissen wir noch
und sogar eine philosophie des opfern
ein mann der einer der sagt wir können
überhaupt nur lesen wir können diese
frage nicht beantworten wir müssen so
tun als ob und das ist das einzige
sinnvolle leben das wir führen können er
gibt noch früher auf ich stimme ihm
nicht zu manchmal müssen wir handeln als
ob aber dann finden heraus dass dieses
als ob nicht die wahrheit ist ich handle
als ob die us verfassung nicht zerstören
kann ich habe keine andere wahl
das heißt aber nicht dass er unsere
verfassung nicht zerstören wird es
könnte ihm gelingen als ob beantwortet
diese frage nicht sondern vermeidet die
konfrontation damit es gibt noch eine
große frage mich seit längerem
beschäftigt ich leitete diese sitzung
ein und er unser gespräch mit der sache
es gibt vielleicht gar keine großen
philosophen mehr
das stimmt nicht das merken wir jetzt
aber es ist doch wahr dass die letzten
30 40 jahre in der philosophie so eine
art stagnation gibt es gab die großen
werke in den 60er 70er jahren und jetzt
hat man das gefühl man bearbeitet diese
fragen nach es gibt keine ganz großen
neuen ansätze ist das eine einschätzung
die sie teilen
ich mache mir sorgen um die nähere
zukunft der philosophie denn tatsächlich
sagen viele es gebe keine großen denker
mehr
obwohl vielleicht weiß ich es einfach
nicht aber nehmen sie zum beispiel rolls
royce professor an der harvard
university und autor von eine theorie
der gerechtigkeit revolutionierte die
philosophie er machte politische und
moralische philosophie auf eine art
möglich die vorher nicht denkbar war
john rawls revolutionierte das fach und
ich sehe heute keine person die
vergleichbares vorweisen könnte aber
vielleicht geht es leute von denen wir
nichts wissen
ein problem mit altmodischen kreuzen wie
mir ist dass sie brillante junge talente
nicht anerkennen
sie schauen immer noch wenn ihre
großeltern bewundert haben sie in
wittgenstein und rossel anstatt junge
universitätsabsolventen zu beachten
vielleicht gibt es brillante leute die
ich nicht kenne aber ich teile ihre
sorge
ich finde keine philosophen die es mit
john rawls aufnehmen könnten
sonst kann ich nichts sagen es gibt wohl
viele die besser sind als ich aber john
rawls war außergewöhnlich er schrieb ein
paar bemerkenswerte dinge
er hatte eine etwas seltsame
angewohnheit die ihm ein normales leben
erschwerte seine frau erzählte mal
meiner frau dass er ständig die namen
seiner kinder vergesse ich mag
vielleicht ein schlechter mensch sein
aber ich vergesse die namen meiner
kinder nicht mehr so fokussiert wie
wahrscheinlich ist es schwierig mit
dieser obsession zu leben aber ich bin
nicht aber es ist ja in dieser weise
schon verwirrend oder oder rätselhaft es
gab wahrscheinlich auf diesem planeten
noch nie so viele so gut ausgebildete
und so gut benotete philosophen er im
moment die noch nie so wenig
interessantes geleistet haben ganz
richtig
da zeigt sich ein problem das ich habe
ich reise viel herum und ich muss sagen
deutsch sprechende länder sind wunderbar
für philosophen in der schweiz und in
deutschland habe ich sehr viele zuhörer
weil man dort philosophie liebt warum
also entstehen dort nicht bessere werke
nun jede gesellschaft muss ein mittel
haben um die jungen zu brechen es gibt
zu viele junge und sie sind zu lange
jung
wir brauchen also methoden um sie zu
brechen sie heißt habilitationsschrift
und ist ein brilliantes mittel um die
jungen zu brechen
man sagt ihnen ihr könnt nicht karriere
machen wenn ihr nicht habilitiert habt
aber ihr könnt ihr erst mit 40 jahren
habilitieren wenn ihr intellektuell
einigermaßen ausgereift zeit um die
jungen zu brechen ist die
habilitationsschrift sehr effektiv die
franzosen haben etwas ähnliches dass
doktor hdt es dauert ewig es zu erlangen
und macht alle fertig bis sie es endlich
geschafft haben
die amerikaner haben dass page die ich
habe nie ein reguläres page die erlangt
ich habe nur ein oxford stiefel aber das
sind mittel um die jungen zu brechen
sie müssen eine symbolträchtige aufgabe
erfüllen
so ist gewährleistet dass junge leute
intellektuell nicht unabhängig sind
bis sie keine bedrohung mehr für die
ältere generation darstellen
dieses problem besteht fast auf dem
klassisch kulturpessimistischen topos
einzahlen der sagt wir sind heute
zunächst zu den jungen menschen die sind
zu verhätschelt die sind so
verweichlicht sie haben ja lange noch
haben sie das gefühl dass die jugend
heute in irgendeiner form nicht mehr die
innere herze bestimmungen hat um nicht
nur in der philosophie sondern an sich
europa zu leisten
ich denke ich bin so streng wie ich
immer war
aber ich beobachte an meiner universität
eine allgemeine lockerung der
anforderungen müssen spaß machen und
dürfe nicht zu lange dauern
außerdem darf man nicht zu viel von den
studenten verlangen
allgemein ist man ihnen gegenüber also
weniger streng
manche universitäten wie es dann wird
lassen keine studenten durchfallen
es wäre schlimm für sie wenn man ihnen
sagen würde sie hätten nicht bestanden
zudem haben sie sehr viel geld
investiert um in stanford zu studieren
es gibt also verschiedene anzeichen
dafür dass wir die anforderungen senken
und weniger streng sind als zur zeit
meines studiums
damals musste man arbeiten wenn man sich
nicht gut vorbereitete bestand man die
prüfungen nicht und die professoren
hatten keine angst uns zu sagen wir
seien durchgefallen
heute ist das schwierig wenn wir von
versagen sprechen oder scheitern dann
gibt es eine form des versagens die
jeden menschen irgendwann trifft der
wird nämlich sterben
ich habe noch nicht darüber gelesen dass
sie sehr viel über den tod der
eigentliche endlichkeit geschrieben
hätte der tod wird mir immer mehr
bewusst sie auch ein philosophisches
thema und wenn ja wie gehen sie damit um
ja es wird auch für nicht zum thema wie
gehen sie mit dem tod um wenn sie eine
antwort gefunden haben sagen sie es mir
denn je älter ich werde desto mehr komme
ich dem tod ich möchte aber nicht
sterben ich habe noch viel zu tun
ich lebe noch und hoffe es bleibt so
ich bin ja erst 85 mein gott ich bin
auch keine alter knabe
aber ich werde älter ich fahre nicht
mehr so gut wie früher
ich werde nie mehr einen riesenslalom
gewinnen das ist mir als kind gelungen
und ich kann es nicht wiederholen was
passiert mit unserem körper und gehirn
wir müssen es akzeptieren und aus dem
was uns bleibt das beste machen
es gibt ein sehr berühmten satz von
sokrates ungarn von montañes der heißt
philosophie sie philosophieren heißt
sterben lernen was machen sie aus diesen
satz er deutet er für sie ich verstehe
den satz nicht und ich habe nicht
gelernt zu sterben ich akzeptiere den
tod nicht und ich befürchte die
akzeptanz des todes führt zu einer art
passivität
wir müssen leben als ehrte unser leben
ewig wir wissen dass wir sterben werden
aber wir kennen unseren todestag nicht
daher müssen wir so leben als ob wir
morgen noch da wären
und zwar jeden tag auf wenn wir wissen
dass irgendwann der tag kommt wo das
nicht mehr zutrifft
das finde ich jetzt als noch jüngere
menschen fast ein bisschen belasten das
heißt ja ich musste mir die ganze zeit
etwas vormachen von dem ich weiß dass es
nicht sein wird ich müsste mich selbst
belügen sie belügen sich nicht und sie
machen sich nichts vor
um es mit einem ausdruck zu sagen den
sie vorher zitiert haben sie tun als ob
sie müssen handeln als ob ihr leben ewig
währen würde denn sonst haben sie nicht
genug motivation und großes anzustreben
dafür muss man motiviert seien und daher
müssen sie so handeln als ob sie ewig
fortfahren und weitere bücher schreiben
könnten
obwohl sie wissen dass es einmal zu ende
sein wird das 20 jahrhundert kann man
sagen dass von ihnen auch stark mit
gestartet wurde war ein philosophisches
jahrhundert der sprache die sprache war
das zentrale thema im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert
meine frage an sie wäre glauben sie dass
wird im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
auch noch so sein oder gibt es
vielleicht ein neues großes thema das
die philosophie begeistert und welches
wäre es ich denke die periode in der die
sprache im zentrum der philosophie stand
war eine sehr nützliche produktive zeit
auch ein großteil meiner arbeit entstand
damals aber jetzt haben wir das
verarbeitet und sind weitergegangen
andere themen sind wichtig geworden für
die philosophen wir haben viel gelernt
und werden bestimmte fehler vermeiden
wie etwa die annahme beim sprechen
würden bilder durch unseren kopf gehen
was hat die sprache ersetzen als ein
mögliches thema schlage ich das
bewusstsein vor lange war das
bewusstsein ein skandal in der
geschichte der philosophie
es sah aus als ob wir zum besseren
verständnis des bewusstseins zu gott der
seele und der unsterblichkeit
zurückkehren müssten
oder schlimmer wir müssen ins bett
steigen mit philosophen welche die
existenz des bewusstseins leugnen in
daniel dennett und andere hingegen denke
wenn wir das bewusstsein als bestandteil
unserer biologie anerkennen dann gibt es
da nichts mystisches kein gott keine
seele oder unsterblichkeit ist
involviert wenn ich magenschmerzen oder
einen kater habe auch nicht in den
ängsten der postindustriellen menschen
im späten kapitalismus ich finde wir
müssen das bewusstsein als biologische
tatsache ansehen dann eröffnet sich ein
weites feld von fragen für die
philosophen
wir sind erst daran an der oberfläche
des bewusstseins zu kratzen
ich könnte mehrere leben lang aber das
bewusstsein schreiben ich habe bis jetzt
erst ein paar bücher geschrieben hätte
und das ist eine frage die mich selber
auch bestätigt man hat in seiner
biografie erlebnisse die ganz groß sind
die kanten sind auch politischer art
1968 64 war vielleicht auch sein lebens
was ist das erlebnis von dem sie hoffen
dass sie es noch erleben werden ohne
dass sie nicht gehen wollten
ich möchte ein buch schreiben mit dem
ich wirklich zufrieden bin
das habe ich noch nie geschafft wenn ich
ein buch geschrieben habe denke ich ich
sollte nochmals von vorne beginnen jetzt
weiß wie es geht
daher möchte ich ein buch schreiben von
dem ich sagen kann dieses buch sagt
wirklich das aus was ich sagen will
am zufriedensten war ich mit dem buch
über intention ali t
daran habe ich jahrelang gearbeitet und
bis zu einem gewissen grad geschrieben
was ich sagen wollte
aber ich stehe noch am anfang ich habe
erst gerade mit der philosophie begonnen
weil ich weiß welche bücher ich
schreiben möchte mit 86 jahren sind sie
ein anfänger der philosophie in der alle
es war eine große freude mit euch zu
sprechen
herzlich aber ich bin aber erst 85
wunderbar schaffen das war ein schönes
gespräch
[Musik]